looma is known for being a tyrant who
gives her mother's reputation a run for
its money but is she really the villain
we paints her out to be like many vks
uma has her reasons for lashing out in
anger we'll be diving into umas
backstory to find out what makes her the
evil pirate we know and fear keep
watching to find out which traumatic
incident caused Emma's personality to
take a turn for the worse Lumis side of
the story
anyone who knows uma would say that
she's a sassy and manipulative pirate
who always has a plan up her sleeve she
was first introduced in descendants to
as an evil foe who had little motive for
her revolution uma was raised by her
mother
Ursula on the Isle of the lost so she
basically grew up with evey mal Jay and
Carlos but what could have caused her to
follow in her mother's footsteps instead
of joining the good side with her old
friends believe it or not but uma has a
lot more motive than we were first led
to believe in fact in her point of view
mal and her crew are every bit to blame
for her actions
although uma is painted as a tyrant we
wouldn't go as far to label her as
heartless that would just be wrong
considering that uma was seen helping
Harry onto the docks mid-battle
now that doesn't sound like something a
selfish person would do it's clear that
whom is tired of being left on the back
burner and desperately wants to be heard
in the end what's so wrong about wanting
to escape from an island you've been
imprisoned on because of something your
mother did before you were born
uma is upbringing before we can begin to
imagine what thoughts run through Emma's
head let's take a gander at her
upbringing this way we can make our
minds up about her ourselves
since descendants - painted uma in a bad
light many of us were quick to judge her
but even the nicest dogs have their
reasons for biting every once in a while
and it looks like uma didn't have the
fairytale childhood people from auradon
are so accustomed to so she's about
ready to bite anyone in sight which
isn't too surprising the sea which was
raised by Ursula who tends to ignore her
daughter unless she needs something in
descendants - uma told Ben that her
mother only remembers she's alive when
the dishes pile up at our salos fish and
chips
knowing this were not surprised that
she's in the rush to ditch the Isle of
the Lost
Ursula apparently spends most of her
time on the couch watching soap operas
so we can assume that she's on the lazy
side can you just imagine how many
chores umas
had to complete throughout her life she
seems more like a modern-day Cinderella
than a heartless villain if you ask us
and since all she's ever known is
villainy how else would she break free
from her James why is new mother way she
is uma has a big personality and her
crew is very fond of it why else would
they choose her as the leader and follow
her blindly into battle uma spent her
life in her mother's shadow obeying her
every single order she threw her way
so since her home life was far from
delightful she found a sense of
happiness and unity by befriending other
BK's on the island
however trusting BK's is always a tricky
business after all they're all born and
raised under the premise that being evil
is the only way to win their parents
affection so why wouldn't they backstab
their friends when the opportunity is
presented is probably something they
learned to do in selfishness 101 despite
her bad rep uma has a big heart and is
known for fighting for the underdog so
it's safe to assume that she was
tremendously hurt whenever her friends
ridiculed her because well it made their
previous connection seem fake and futile
sure
uma might be manipulative and sneaky but
she's just playing the game to come out
on top is that not what mal evj and
Carlos used to do once upon a time and
where we're standing and looks like uma
is angry and tired of being backed into
a corner
why does uma hate mal so much it's no
secret that Mau used to be the aisles
big bad before she moved to auradon so
we're not too surprised that some of the
vks don't really like her sure they
might fear her but they don't respect
her at least not anymore this is
especially true since she turned on her
own mother and prevented the villains
from escaping the Isle of the Lost but
that still doesn't explain why uma is
hell-bent on destroying nas life she
must have a really good reason for doing
so though because well people don't just
kidnap each other's boyfriends without
proper cause it might surprise you to
know that mal and Goomer were once super
good friends in the book rise of the
Isle of the Lost
it's revealed that uma mal and Maddy
used to be the Isles three amigos they
wrecked havoc on everyone and had a
stellar reputation but one day mounted
something unforgivable and it's fueled
Emma's hatred ever since the old crew
had come up with a plan to prank the
unpleasent Cruella De Vil midway through
their plan though
I fell off the dock and into the water
uma knew all too well that now couldn't
swim so she jumped in after her in an
attempt to save her life this moment of
kindness didn't go unnoticed and it made
oma appear weak in the eyes of her
mother unfortunately it was all a ruse
concocted by mal herself when Emma
jumped into the water mal appeared
behind her and dumped a bucket of cold
and slimy shrimp on her head everyone
laughed and ridiculed uma calling her
shrimpy an unfortunate nickname that
stuck knowing what you now know who's
the real villain uma or mal still at the
same time mal was just doing what she
thought was expected of her and she's
living proof that evil people can change
so if the girls were ever to have a
heart to heart do you think Yuma's
allegiances could follow suit we'll come
back to this topic at the end of the
video so stick around to find out if
redemption could be a Numis feature the
V case go to our time prep years may
have passed since mal publicly
humiliated uma but Emma's hair still
smells of pungent shrimp the stench was
a constant reminder of Mouse betrayal
but uma swallowed her pride and kept
working at Ursula's fish and chips at
this point
uma must have been dreaming of a life in
auradon and what it could be like to
live among a kind society whereas mal
would go in to make new friends and
forget about her old pal uma continued
to harness her rage and resentment
something in Amos snapped when she found
out that mal evey Carlos NJ had been
chosen to attend our don prep the news
was the cherry on top of Emma's
misfortune out of everyone on the aisle
that bin could have picked he chose the
one BK who was known for terrorizing and
blame the population to make matters
worse mal was tasked with freeing the
Isle of the lost and everyone was
rooting for her where was umas
invitation what about her dreams
after watching mal and her friends get
escorted to our don prep uma sol an
opportunity to get some respect so the
sea which quickly made light of her dark
situation meanwhile while mal
evey Carlos and Jay are making new
friends in ara dine uma is doing
something similar back home her hatred
for mouth fueled her every move and she
soon began in building a reputation of
her own with mal gone she could finally
take place as number one uma joined
forces with Harry
and skill and began to form a pirate
crew that was growing in numbers every
day with Harry as her first mate
uma took on the task of freeing the
villains from the Isle of the Lost
Mao soon turned her mother into a lizard
and turned her back on her fellow BK's
causing more of them to flock to Emma's
cause uma promised that she would avenge
them and take whatever opportunity came
her way her plan thickened when mal
returned home and been followed suits
the Pirates kidnapped him hoping that he
would be traded in for their freedom but
mal was one step out of them fumus plans
were stomped on by the VIII case
fashionable boots bringing her rage to a
whole new level
Pumas weakness like everyone in this
world uma has her individual set of
strengths and weaknesses while she makes
an excellent leader she can be a little
too trusting at times sure Mao made a
dog start talking while using the fairy
godmothers wand but uma should have
known that mal wasn't actually going to
hand her the most powerful tool in
auradon let's be real if mal had
actually been holding the real wand
why wouldn't she have used it to save
Ben and return to our Adan handing it
over to the villain made no sense and
went against mouths nature you don't
trade in the fairy godmothers one to
save your boyfriend you use the one to
save him this is something new my
quickly realised when she tried to
destroy the barrier and failed once
again she was one-upped by her old BFF
and her reputation took a big hit for
being too trusting
much like mal uma can use magic at will
and transform into a beast still mouths
dragon form locked
Emma's octopus form out of the park and
sadly uma was back to square one Lumis
master plan during the V Ches time at
our on prep uma came close to snagging
the fairy godmothers one as well as King
Triton's trident unfortunately for her
she ended up being bested by Mau on both
accounts regardless of this Houmas time
was not wasted in the end she acquired a
crew a ship and a new purpose
oome is not one to give up easily which
is something we clearly saw and under
the sea a descendant short story it's
here that we find out that emma is
coming for mal
for the third time it's also where we
find out that emma can possess other
people's bodies and talk through them
mal asks mo why she thinks she'll be
victorious this time around but uma is
quick to tell her that this time now
we'll never see her coming
all this combined with the mysterious
blue orb in the forest is a call for
concern and now quickly realizes that
something big is headed in our Dynes
direction Loomis father if there's one
question descendants fans keep asking
themselves it's why don't the BK's have
fathers for some strange reason most of
our favorite characters are being raised
by single mothers and we want some
answers some fans believe that Houmas
father is none other than dr. facile ear
and we got to admit that this makes a
little sense Mumma might be able to
transform into a hybrid octopus but her
natural form is one of a human so we can
assume that her dad is a human as well
and since Puma has a dark complexion
fans will eat that her father and mother
are both dark-skinned too so this makes
us set our sights on dr. Basso Pierre
who totally could have had fling with
Ursula some were quick to point out that
China and MacLean who plays uma is
sisters with Lauren MacLean who plays
dr. facile ears daughter Freddy and
since they bear a striking resemblance
to one another we believe that they're
casting wasn't a coincidence do you guys
think that dr. fossil ear could be
Emma's dad sound off in the comments
section what does d3 have in store for
Emma you know the saying the enemy of my
enemy is my friend
well apparently Len now know the saying
all too well we were shocked to see uma
Harry and Gil fighting alongside the
BK's to beat a group of men in armor in
the d3 trailer this scene quickly
flashes across the screen but it looks
like uma is on mouths side for once
could their common enemy make them put
their differences aside or will Loomis
strike for the kill
once the common threat is defeated we
would love to see Emma receive an
invitation to auradon after she shows
her true colors what do you guys think
will Emma find herself fighting evil to
protect the fate of the world looks like
we'll have to wait until the summer of
2019 to find out give this video a big
thumbs up if you think emma is how the
wicked and don't forget to subscribe to
the things for the latest descendants
news thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]